as more students start going back to
campus a new initiative aims to promote
helmet safety
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the pilot program started by
the clark county school district police
department
from bmx tricks
to wheelchair back flips action sports
celebrities aaron fotheringham and
jonathan bronson visit doc romeo park in
the northwest
valley to not just show off their skills
but share an important message just want
to help and
talk to the kids about helmet safety
just show that you know helmets aren't
lame the duo are partnering with the
clark county school district police
department
to promote the start of pop-up helmet
giveaways at
skateparks who wants a helmet you want a
helmet if we need to get one
stop one fatality or injury that's the
main goal
officer terry mcinich leads this effort
after noticing
a troubling trend kids would knock out
their online stuff and
i've seen more kids at the skate park so
i'd stop in and say hi
and start noticing you know they don't
have helmets but they don't really have
a
we didn't have an avenue to get them the
department normally does a free helmet
giveaway with jaguar land rover las
vegas once a year but
mackinac wants to improve the outreach
with the dealership
especially now as more children go back
to campuses instead of doing a one shot
that
parents may not be able to get to with
their kids now they're going to go
i guess you would say fish where the
fish are and go where the children
actually need them the most
working to prevent another statistic by
encouraging safety
been quite a few accidents of students
have been hitting in cars on the way to
or from school
and the ones with helmets i see it in a
few days back
at school the ones without sometimes are
in the hospital for a while before we
see them
while also developing community
engagement kristin drummond
8 news now the department plans to
reward children seen wearing helmets at
skate parks with
prizes ccsd pd reports up to 25
of children under the age of 14 use
helmets kids between ages of 11 and 14
are the least
likely though to wear a bicycle helmet